seguro que alguna vez te lo has
preguntado porque hay países con formas
tan raras por ejemplo os habéis fijado
alguna vez en la forma que tiene y
croacia porque tiene esa especie de
cuernos saliendo para abajo puede
parecer una tontería pero ese cuerno es
lo que hace que bosnia herzegovina el
país vecino no tenga salida al mar y qué
pasa con rusia porque tienen esa especie
de isla está entre lituania y polonia
quiero decir quien ha decidido que esa
región que por cierto se llama
kaliningrado sea parte de rusia pero sin
duda alguna los países con las formas
más raras del planeta son armenia y
azerbaiyán si os fijáis veréis que
azerbaiyán tiene un trozo de país al
otro lado de armenia pero dentro de
azerbaiyán hay otra región que de facto
está controlada por armenia como os
podéis imaginar todo esto son más que
líneas en un mapa estamos hablando de
uno de los conflictos más complejos de
la política internacional un conflicto
que puede que esté a punto de resolverse
este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a la
conferencia de seguridad de múnich pero
no sólo porque hayan colaborado con
nosotros
para hacerlo es que son parte importante
de toda esta historia al final del vídeo
vais a entender muchas cosas sobre quién
dibuja las fronteras así que vamos con
nuestra historia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
armenia azerbaiyán son dos de esos
países que solo vas a oír mencionar en
eurovisión y aquí en visual político
estos dos países son vecinos y tienen un
montón de cosas en común de entrada
ambos fueron repúblicas soviéticas ambos
son países extremadamente corruptos
[Música]
azerbaiyán es el coto privado de la
familia alíyev y armenia ha estado
dirigida durante décadas por una élite
de oligarcas por si esto fuera poco en
ambos países hablan idiomas
impronunciables para que os hagáis una
idea los armenios tienen hasta su propia
caligrafía única en el mundo con tantas
similitudes alguno pensará bueno pues
seguro que se llevan bien verdad o es
nada de eso
armenia y azerbaiyán se odian pero pero
que se odian de verdad el conflicto
entre estos dos países se ha llevado por
delante a miles de vidas en las últimas
tres décadas y millones de desplazados
vamos que no tienen nada que envidiarle
a los israelíes y los palestinos
y diréis pero bueno fonseca porque nunca
hemos oído hablar de este conflicto pues
básicamente porque aquí no hay ni
izquierdas ni derechas en este caso
rusia ha estado apoyando siempre los
armenios y turquía a los azerbaiyanos
eeuu y la unión europea pasan
olímpicamente de esta historia y como
aquí tampoco hay buenos las víctimas
pues la verdad que nos importan más bien
poco a estas alturas muchos os
preguntaréis y por qué se harían tanto
es por una cuestión de ideologías es por
religión por recursos naturales pues
nada de eso es cierto que los armenios
son cristianos y los azerbaiyanos
también llamados azeríes son musulmanes
pero no la religión no es la razón la
manzana de la discordia es este pedazo
de tierra que veis aquí
[Música]
esta región de aquí se llama nagorno
cámara y tiene unos 140 mil habitantes
de los cuales el 90% habla armenia
armenia dice que eso les pertenece pero
oficialmente este trozo de tierra
pertenece a azerbaiyán y diréis pero que
hay en esa región tienen petróleo pues
no alguna importancia estratégica la más
mínima entonces porque os contamos esta
historia aquí en visual político pues
por tres razones la primera es porque
puede que este conflicto se resuelva muy
pronto la segunda es porque hemos tenido
el privilegio de ver en directo uno de
los episodios de esta historia y si digo
hemos porque esto ha ocurrido delante de
mis propios ojos como sabéis
visual político es uno de los medios a
los que invitaron para ir a la
conferencia de seguridad de múnich y
justo en el hotel donde se celebró esta
conferencia es donde se produjo una de
estas conversaciones de paz
es decir que muchas de las cosas que os
voy a contar las he visto yo mismo con
mis propios ojos comprenderéis que
no ve historia en directo todos los días
así que como os podéis imaginar tenía
que hacer este vídeo pero es que además
hay una tercera razón esta es una de
esas historias que demuestra lo absurda
que puede ser la política muchas veces
porque si aquí hablamos de dos países
matándose por un trozo de tierra que no
varía absolutamente nada no tiene
petróleo no tenía valor estratégico nada
esto creo que podría servirnos a muchos
para darnos cuenta de lo absurdos que
son muchos debates en los que nos
podemos dejar la piel defendiendo una
postura y espero que muchos de vosotros
os pongáis a reflexionar pero bueno la
pregunta es que está pasando entre
armenia y azerbaiyán
porque si odian a muerte tiene solución
a este conflicto pues hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
la paz que nadie quería la pregunta la
gran pregunta es pero quien llegó
primero a nagorno karabaj los armenios o
los azeríes y la respuesta ya os la
podéis imaginar depende a quién
preguntes lo que sí podemos decir es que
durante los años 20 del siglo 20 la
mayoría de la población era armenia en
este momento es cuando llego stalin y
conquistó toda la región para luego
dividirla en tres repúblicas socialistas
georgia armenia y azerbaiyán y como hizo
la división stalin pues un poco como le
dio la gana
así que básicamente en el año 1923
stalin llegó y dijo esto de nagorno
karabakh va a ser parte de azerbaiyán
por qué pues porque lo digo yo que soy
esta línea que acallar todo el mundo la
unión soviética ya sabéis que nunca tuvo
muchos miramientos a la hora de dibujar
fronteras y ninguna etnia ni movimiento
nacionalista se atrevía a cuestionar las
decisiones de moscú así que hasta el año
1987 ninguna gornja no se atrevió a
decir que quería formar parte de armenia
y qué pasó en el año 1987 pues que la
unión soviética empezaba a desintegrarse
y de repente toda esa población armenia
organizó un referéndum de
autodeterminación para salirse de
azerbaiyán y hacer posible formar parte
de armenia como os podéis imaginar esto
fue la chispa que generó la famosa
guerra entre armenia y azerbaiyán guerra
que duró hasta 1994
seis años de conflicto que se llevaron
por delante a más de 30 mil vidas y más
de un millón de desplazados
[Música]
y diréis quién ganó la guerra pues en la
práctica podemos decir que armenia
oficialmente en nagorno karabaj forma
parte de azerbaiyán pero la realidad es
que la región está controlada por la
república de arzak donde la lengua la
divisa y hasta los bancos son los mismos
que en armenta
por si esto fuera poco todos los
alrededores de esta zona están
controlados por el ejército armenio
vamos que aunque casi ningún país
reconozca arzak como una región armenia
en la práctica lo es y diréis y qué pasa
con los azeríes que viven por esa zona
pues lo cierto es que casi todos se
tuvieron que marchar tras la guerra si
contamos con los que vivían en esta
región y los que vivían en armenia
hablamos de alrededor de 800.000 azeríes
que como sabéis son los habitantes o los
pertenecientes a la etnia de azerbaiyán
y algo parecido ocurrió con los armenios
que vivían por azerbaiyán conclusión a
día de hoy ambos pueblos se odian y de
verdad que no exagero para muestra un
botón en el año 2005 el por entonces
alcalde de bakú la capital de azerbaiyán
tuvo una reunión oficial con una
delegación alemana pues atentos a la
perla que les soltó porque es que no
tiene desperdicio
nuestro objetivo es la completa
eliminación de los armenios vosotros
tuvisteis a los nazis que eliminarán a
los judíos entre los años 30 y los años
40 no seguro que nos entendéis hanibal a
abu talib o alcalde de bakú en el año
sin comentarios y alguno todavía me dirá
vale bueno pero esto es lo que ha dicho
un alcalde por ahí bueno pues atentos a
lo que dice el actual presidente de
azerbaiyán que se llama elham aller
atentos nuestros principales enemigos
son los armenios del mundo entero y los
hipócritas y políticos corruptos bajo su
control
ilham alíyev presidente de azerbaiyán si
sois veteranos seguidores de visual
política el nombre de alí llevo
resultará familiar ya sabéis que
hablamos de un dictador corrupto como
pocos y como sabéis a los dictadores
corruptos les encanta señalar a un
enemigo sean los yanquis los judíos o en
este caso los armenios y todo esto
explica que cada vez que alguien haya
intentado sentar en la misma mesa a
alguien de armenia y azerbaiyán para que
negocien un acuerdo de paz han fracasado
seamos honestos a ninguna de las dos
partes les interesa que haya paz y
diréis pero hay algún posible acuerdo de
verdad es posible solucionar este
desaguisado pues claro que sí veréis en
el año 2009 la [ __ ]
sentó en una mesa al yen y al entonces
presidente de armenia donde lo hicieron
en madrid españa ahí sacaron una serie
de principios los principios de madrid
básicamente estos principios consisten
en que por un lado los habitantes de
nagorno o cabras o si lo preferís llamar
así de la repubblica de arsa podrían
decidir si quieren ser armenia
azerbaiyán el ejército armenio por
supuesto tendría que retirarse de las
zonas de alrededor de la región y
azerbaiyán tendría que garantizar un
corredor entre la región y armenia tiene
sentido verdad pues sí tenerlo lo tiene
pero ninguna de las dos partes está
dispuesta a aceptarlo a fin de cuentas
tener un hombre del saco ha venido de
perlas a sus oligarcas tanto los de un
país como los del otro sin embargo ahora
las cosas pueden cambiar porque pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
el outsider armenia armenia es uno de
los pocos países del mundo que tiene más
gente fuera que dentro tal cual como lo
oís veréis dentro de armenia viven unos
3 millones de habitantes pero es que la
diáspora armenia son más de 10 millones
de personas y están repartidos por todo
el mundo y diréis pero porque hay tanta
gente marchándose de armenia pues si
veis las cifras está más que claro
tienen más de un 20% de para una renta
per cápita equiparable a la de namibia y
toda la corrupción que os podáis
imaginar y de nuevo el conflicto en
nagorno karabaj es la excusa perfecta
para justificar lo absolutamente todo es
más en este caso podríamos decir que
casi todas las élites políticas vienen
de esta región de hecho el ex primer
ministro de armenia nació en la
república de arsat pero es que el ex ex
primer ministro de armenia también nació
en la república de arzak y lo mismo
ocurre con montones y altos cargos y
creedme por extraño que parezca la
dichosa república de arzak es la
prioridad número uno de todos los
gobiernos que ha tenido este
armenia podía tener toda la corrupción
que os podáis imaginar problemas
económicos de desempleo pero sus
presidentes hacían cosas tan útiles para
los ciudadanos como tratar de convencer
al gobierno de tuvalú para que
reconociera la república de arzak como
república independiente y soberana y si
habéis oído bien
tuvalú un país de estos perdidos por el
pacífico que solamente descubrir que
existen cuando los veis en visual
político y la lista sigue a día de hoy
hay seis estados de eeuu que reconocen
la república de arzak y diréis estados
dentro de eeuu que pinta california
reconociendo estados soberanos pues nada
pero así es como han estado justificando
el sueldo montones de políticos armenios
durante años así hasta que llegamos al
año 2018
i
las protestas armenias derrocaron a un
primer ministro
exacto os lo explicamos aquí en visual
político en 2018 los armenios estaban
hasta la coronilla de tantos años de
corrupción abuso de poder y la
consecuente pobreza que conlleva y
echaron por fin a su primer ministro el
nuevo gobierno armenio está encabezado
por este señor que veis en pantalla
nicole para xinjiang en sus primeros dos
años de gobierno ha hecho varias
reformas económicas y parece que está
luchando contra la corrupción seriamente
y diréis y que piensa este señor del
conflicto pues la verdad es que no
piensa nada que os vaya a sorprender
[Música]
brazilian hace un llamamiento a la
unificación de armenia con karabaj y ya
sé lo que estaréis pensando pues nada
nuevo bajo el sol verdad pues sí y a la
vez no veréis primero para xinjiang es
el primer primer ministro en años que no
ha nacido en la república de arzak
segundo es un absoluto outsider de las
élites armenias en otras palabras que él
no necesita agitar el miedo contra
azerbaiyán para ganar popularidad y por
eso decimos que hay una ventana de
oportunidad para negociar un acuerdo de
paz la pregunta es cómo se negocian los
acuerdos de paz pues atentos porque
ahora mismo os lo voy a contar
[Música]
a diferencia de seguridad de múnich
imagina por un momento que a ti te
contratan como asesor del gobierno de
armenia y que tienes como misión
negociar o empezar las negociaciones con
azerbaiyán por donde empezaría supongo
que buscaría algún listín telefónico que
te habría dejado el anterior gobierno
donde esté el teléfono del palacio
presidencial de bakú vale vamos a
suponer que llamas por teléfono y dices
hola mira que si está le llevó a alguien
del gobierno de por ahí que yo llamo del
gobierno de armenia para hablar del tema
este de lo de nagorno te cuelgan el
teléfono cuelgan el teléfono porque es
que eres el enemigo pues bien para eso
están las conferencias políticas en este
tipo de eventos es donde se juntan los
líderes políticos de todo el mundo para
poderse hablar de tú a tú pues bien de
todas estas conferencias políticas la
conferencia de seguridad de múnich es
una de las más grandes
de nuestra misión consiste en ofrecer
una plataforma relativamente cómoda para
que la gente que tiene problemas en
visitar el país del otro
porque lo considera un paso
especialmente duro
steve y cold step que a lo mejor si
visitan un país adversario van a perder
apoyos este señor que acabáis de ver es
world gun y singer el director de la
conferencia de seguridad de múnich
básicamente este señor es como el
maestro de ceremonias él y su equipo
tienen una lista con todos los nombres
de los políticos que van a asistir a la
conferencia así que en este caso podrías
hablar con él y decirle mira wolfgang
que es que queremos contactar color de
azerbayán que ya sabes que tenemos ahí
nuestros temas pendientes y
probablemente el señor wolfgang te
pasaría el contacto de algún
representante del gobierno de azerbaiyán
no sé si esto es exactamente lo que pasó
pero os puedo asegurar que algo parecido
ocurrió en esta edición de la
conferencia de seguridad de múnich
atentos y prestando a derval young
el presidente de azerbaiyán y el primer
ministro de armenia tienen un conflicto
un conflicto llamado nagorno karabaj que
lleva más de 30 años y donde se mata a
gente continuamente tal vez no en
grandes números pero si continuamente
así que ayer organizamos una sesión para
esos dos y me dijeron que era la primera
vez que se dejaban ver juntos mis éxitos
están wisteria de beni web tal cual como
lo oís y esto os lo puedo contar porque
es que he estado yo y lo he visto yo con
mis propios ojos para xinjiang y alguien
estuvieron discutiendo juntos en el
mismo escenario y diréis venga ya
fonseca me vas a decir ahora que dos
líderes que se odian a muerte han pasado
de quererse matar a darse las manitas y
cantar el kumbala para la foto pues
obviamente no de hecho en el debate se
dedicaron a discutir sobre datos
históricos para justificar porque
nagorno karabaj tenía que ser de un lado
o de otro y desde luego que no fue una
charla amigable pero también es cierto
que en este tipo de conferencias lo
menos importantes son las charlas del
escenario
la verdadera acción es lo que ocurre en
las cafeterías en los pasillos del hotel
incluso en las habitaciones porque si en
este tipo de conferencias la mayor parte
de las conversaciones de paz se negocian
en habitaciones habitaciones de hotel
que por supuesto se acondicionan para
las reuniones bilaterales así que la
próxima vez que oigas hablar que los
países han firmado un acuerdo pensad que
muy probablemente esto se ha podido
discutir en el sofá de la suite de un
hotel
[Música]
y por lo que se contaba durante la
conferencia tanto la delegación de
azerbaiyán como la de armenia tuvieron
ocasiones de verse y de hablar juntos y
compartir puntos de vista significa esto
que ya han firmado un acuerdo de paz
pues no significa que parece que puedan
llegar a un acuerdo pero en este caso no
puedo mostraros ningún dato solamente mi
percepción personal y rumores y si lo sé
aquí en visual político nos gusta basar
todo lo que decimos en datos
contrastados y estadísticas no en cuatro
rumores que hemos oído por ahí pero es
que en este caso todavía no hay otra
cosa y diréis pero a ver fonseca y tú
qué hacías allí en la conferencia de
seguridad de múnich esa pues veréis yo
fui a hacer entrevistas de hecho aquí en
visual polític publicamos una que hice
al ex secretario general de la otan
javier solana pero también entrevistado
a mucha más gente por ejemplo me pareció
muy interesante la conversación que tuve
con david miliband que fue uno de los
grandes ideólogos de tony blair también
entrevisté a peter noiman que es un
experto en radicalismo así que tenéis
un montón de material para pasar un buen
rato y que lo tenéis colgado en este
canal george m si podéis encontrar el
link en la descripción
mientras tanto os dejo con esta pregunta
creéis que armenia y azerbaiyán
terminarán llegando a un acuerdo de paz
qué consecuencias puede tener esto para
estos dos países
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a visual
político y dadle la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto